everyone this is Steve Allen show up
with collider.com
and I am here with director Chad sterile
ski or John wick three how are you doing
sir good thanks for having me I'm super
thankful that you are here especially in
the middle of your press tour and I'm
what you guys probably can't see on
camera is a crowded theater before we
get started I want to give a huge thank
you to Lionsgate for being an awesome
partner and letting a screen the movie
early I want to give a huge thank you
a huge thank you to everyone at IMAX
because IMAX is easily the best way to
watch a movie
the format's incredible you can see John
wick three for one week in IMAX starting
Friday uh let's start immediately with
IMAX uh you any feelings I love MX only
way to go right IMAX but I mean in all
seriousness it's it's an incredible
format and if you've never seen it
before this is the movie to start on and
you can see behind us the screen is
massive jumping into why I get to talk
to you first
congratulations on the movie movie is I
don't want to curse but it's an
incredible well F in thank you so
jumping backwards you finish John wick -
at what point did the studio say to you
the movie comes out opening weekend it
does well at what point does Lionsgate
call you and say hey uh are you thinking
about a third I think it was probably
yeah maybe two days Monday Tuesday maybe
by Wednesday we got all say would you be
interested in thinking about number
three and you know and I said sure give
us a couple weeks to think we took a
couple of weeks and we thought about it
and we said we're gonna need a couple
more weeks we just want to make sure
that we could come up with an idea and
had some thoughts that were gonna be
worthy of the time and the commitment
and all your fan thank you miss and then
yeah I think you know I we really love
the world we love the character I love
working with you and yeah we went back
to Lansky and said yeah I think we have
a few ideas and we'd like to give it a
go and then we started development so at
that point you have you're thinking okay
I'm gonna do the third movie the
you guys designed such incredible action
set-pieces
at one point in the development process
is it like that day the early thinking
about how are we gonna top ourselves and
how you know what I mean like how does
that come together um I don't think
we've ever really had the thought of how
do we top ourselves we certainly don't
try to go bigger or better we just try
to do that's like all you guys you have
a good day you know you want to have
another good day I don't know if you
won't have a bigger day but you have a
better day so you know we have a big
notebook we have a big office with all
these ideas on the wall and some things
made it to the first gemway
some things make it to the second john
waite and some things end up in the
notebook a lot of it is an open
development like we like the joke that
we're we're incredibly backasswards in
the job world we don't write the script
first we have our vision board the big
ball with all these great pictures and
photos of actors and casts we love or
references or latin phrases or locations
you know pictures just of a horse good
idea
I love architecture I love music so
you'll have a you know you'll have a
picture of or something reminds you have
Beethoven or Ivaldi or Hayden and then
you'll see something of you know I have
this big parvo Geo
I love Renaissance art sculptures
anything that'll spark something and
then we start crafting we had a big
picture of a desert don't wick soot
desert great weight story then Keano guy
and start working with characters and
threads you know I told Keanu like look
I'd love to have this ninja guy and then
zero he's the zero of every that's great
I'm gonna have something called an
adjudicator I mean that's great I looked
at word up and it was like okay judge
we're gonna judge this and then you know
we need someone that's gonna be the
moral rather than just have a specter
like bad guy association that's gonna
deal with the financials we're gonna
have a moral guide to the underworld
we're gonna call him the elder but he's
not gonna be old okay write all that
down and then I'll write a fifty sixty
page story almost in bookworm and then
we start branching out the writers let
me start actually developing the script
but to your point for all the ideas it
kind of comes that way a lot of it is as
we're writing I'll go and start scouting
a city like in number two was Rome or
New York and literally I was walking
through Central Park it was almost
Christmas time it was freezing out and I
was walking with my production designer
Gavin Kavanagh
and we're like Jesus it's freezing out
here like where they put the horse so we
asked the guy that did one of the
parodies I know right over there like
over where he's like right across Fifth
Avenue there's a stable and you're
looking this is the brownstone like you
know and sure enough you walk in it's
four levels of horses and we just
started smiling going oh don't wait
coming in here and then you know you
take that okay John wick runs into
stables in Manhattan okay no one will
believe that that'll be fun great great
and then I recalled this incident where
you know as a stunt performer way back
when I got kicked by a horse and it
wasn't as bad as what you guys saw but
like it hurt
so I'm like yeah my horse okay good um I
wrote that and then kind of like I love
westerns you love westerns I love
Western you know the Sergio Leone thing
that we're all fans of he's like Don wet
suit right a horse right right a horse I
got one better ride a horse your brother
good so we start designing stuff that
way and then you know like the knife
fight you guys saw it's a culmination of
who here has ever thrown a knife a
degree okay did it ever stay
me neither hit me right ahead - so
with our company Agra 1587 11 guys and
stuff we try to subvert all the time
doing every action move you ever seen
Hiro picked up a knife he throws it what
happens
dead nut sticks right on you were like
yeah that's never happened to us so what
do you say John with just misses a lot
and I grew up with my brothers in
Massachusetts and we had a snowball
fight again you know I was always one
and then they were to make as many
snowballs as you can you get you just
start talking and see win by four so we
thought we'd have a missing snowball
fight with knives right snowball fight
with knives and that was the brief to
the stunt team you know we just gonna
come up with ideas like that you know
ride horse but not well got it
ride motorcycles with sword got so in
the in the pre-production process you're
coming up with these ideas talk a little
bit about how long it takes to actually
implement these things because I want to
give credit 8711 you know your company
does incredible work and does incredible
work for so many different movies but so
say you're gonna be filming and let's
arbitrarily say June when are you
breaking down the set piece in terms of
designing it and putting it together um
you know if you're talking about the
martial art side of things or
choreography we start pretty early on
depending on the classic Anna we'll
start almost six-month they'll I mean
it's not like you don't jump in and do
eight hours a day it's like everybody
here you got to get in shape to get in
shape nobody here couldn't survive a two
hours straight workout you start with a
half-hour workout tape now I'll work out
it passes know to break them in slowly
they don't get injured everybody gets
but he pulls a muscle everybody tired
yeah
break him in a little far out and then
you know there's the new skill set make
anybody here you know to get him to do
the splits might take a little bit
longer than I do doodle
so you kind of work your way in like
that it's the other stuff that gets a
little trickier um luckily we you know
we have Jana who's been in the action
world for a long time he owns his own
motorcycle company he's been on horses
his whole career he's fired weapons he's
done martial art though burger if he's a
lot tougher than you think it's not
learning martial arts learning the dance
learning with the you know more like
dance in any real martial art because
you have to remember the choreography
we learned skill but again he's good at
that it was probably the animal stuff
what we wanted to do with the dogs look
it about that well I actually I want to
get into the dogs but I want to actually
do get something before we get to your
dogs so Halle Berry is incredible in
this when did you realize that she would
be able to do everything she does in
this movie spoil without I don't wanna
do spoilers but she kicks a lot of ass
and so talk a little bit about that and
then let's get into the dog um we
haven't it was right after the incident
uh Joe's right after Christmas and we
just started working on Laurie in the
trip and we knew we wanted a really
strong counter you know we had always
seen like we're like this is for the
role and that had gone out over the
wires like look this is gonna be a
heavily physical role you know who out
there who has clients that may be
interested in the huge commitment it's
gonna be a six month commitment not
gonna be able to take another job so and
that's tricky like in Hollywood is
people to realize most chimes on a movie
yet what we rehearse right you know the
bigger the name asked the less time you
have because they're booked on these are
the job when you start training or
something like a matrix a or a big
superhero movie like that's the massive
myth that means you can't take any more
money you can't take another job you
can't go to your kids basketball game
you're gonna live
Oh define somebody like that it's tricky
that wants to commit and then I got a
call from WME saying Halle Berry would
like me
when today okay
and her down literally Holly was at my
door couple hours later and I had never
met her and how he came in and said look
I'm a big fan of the first two John
would like be in your movie I'm like
that's I'm gladder that's amazing just
you know we haven't read the script yet
she's like no no no IIIi don't care I'm
like yeah well I think your agents would
probably care you know like there's no
script I don't even know the character's
name is Jeff she's like that's okay we
can figure that out I really gonna be in
your movie and and I was trying to be
you know somewhat bull but again Halle
Berry hard to say no like I was really
flattered and you know she looked
amazing she's an incredible shape like
I'm gonna be in your movie and I'm like
well okay she's like no I'm serious you
don't understand I try to give her an
outgoing like look I'll get back to when
we have the script but work around it
will start writing apart she's like yeah
yeah that's all great but I'm going to
be in your movie like it's gonna be six
months a trench that great when we start
I'm like no like you don't understand
the die it's gonna be fun for a week and
it's just gonna suck like the diet the
three times there's three different
workouts you have to do you have to do
this dogs for anything yeah the martial
arts you go to firearm training and yes
it's none teams like yeah I got it I'm
like everybody says that but no one gets
it and like yeah she never missed a day
so I don't know she hired me and I hired
her but that's kind of like that I got
to tell you the level what she does on
screen is very impressive and nowlet's
without getting into any spoilers in the
trailers and images you've seen she has
dogs he does and so um I don't want to
say exactly what happens on screen but
she what she did to have those dogs
perform the way they did on screen is
crazy and I don't think a lot of people
know what she did and you could sort of
talk about that um I guess again if
people don't know when you an animal any
type of animal that you see on screen
they don't know it's a movie
you guys get there's no such thing as a
movie dog or a movie they've been
trained to do certain things in a movie
environment but they're animals they
don't come out of their trailers they
don't you know they're just and
so when you see a dog do a dog attack on
screen in a film that's actually a dog
trying to injure a human being they
don't know what play they're actually
attack human and then either the Train
of the stunt person who's in Kevlar gear
or body armor and they're trying to
survive
um that wasn't gonna work for us you
know we figured that it wasn't gonna do
well um those of you that haven't been
on a set before it's a pretty chaotic
place there's background going around
you know at any given time with 30 40
stuntmen we have multiple animals on set
firearms a lots going on cameras running
everywhere and most of the time we see
like a dog attack on screen it's what is
it wider shot or a type shot it's one
person be attacked by one dog so we just
said how can we make this the most
impossibly hard thing and we could do we
tried to do it the way you've just
witnessed on screen but what it would
have to take is after we talk to Andrew
Simpson he's the guy that does all the
wolves on Game of Thrones probably in my
mind the best animal trainer in
Hollywood anywhere in the world right
now um he's just like the dog whisperer
but we said look I don't want to do that
I don't want to do real tracks is there
a way you start from scratch and train
these animals to actually be part of the
stunt they actually teach him jujitsu
moves and all this stuff and have him
acclimated he's like oh yeah absolutely
no absolutely take a year of your life
and you'll find special dogs and you'd
have to have a stunt team and a cast
that was willing to work with him for
five to six months and I went
[Music]
and that's it and we spent all our money
train dogs for a year so Andrew went
around the United States found five
Belgian Malinois Belgian Shepherd from
different military installations that
had not yet begun their training and he
found him with the physical and mental
and personality attitude that we were
looking for and we got five and it
started literally uh three weeks later
where the dogs were trained with the
trainer's first then we brought in the
first dozen stuntmen to train with them
all the dogs know you by smell or acme
though when the dogs are release
everyone says they love dogs until
there's a hundred and ten pound animals
right then you have some reserves and
the dogs wreck that so we found the
stuntmen that had the the best mental
aptitude towards animals that were angry
and the dogs and then became very very
close friends and after that we had to
acclimate the dogs to the cameraman and
since of firearms to all the noise and
sound that were going off and then
because we wider and we try to do a lot
of intricate long takes just like we do
with the the martial art stuff the dogs
needed to stay in the shop
which if you don't know they can't have
leashes on them or the trainer can't be
right on camera the what the rather than
have painters in green suits we just had
Hallie be the trainer Ellie not only to
be friends with dog take the dogs home
deliver the dog feed the dog the cuddle
and play with the dogs but to actually
training command them on set so when you
see her on screen giving the Arabic
words of man's she's actually
though that a little
I don't want to obviously get into the
specifics at the film but I think in the
trailers you've seen it's part of the
Morocco set piece and I think we would
all agree you all just saw the movie
without spoilers that set-piece is
jaw-dropping it's crazy what you do and
there's always two dogs doing stuff I I
don't know if I've ever seen a movie do
what you did yeah no yeah yeah well we
kind of call it porn sorry
there's martial art born gun porn sword
porn we just are a little way of that
was like our our we wanted anyone to
know that's work with animals before
like yeah we didn't cheat this like
there's two dogs on we wanted to hand
off and come back and kind of show you
that they're not goofing around and it
wasn't a digital dog it was all all real
dog um it was a lot of time and effort
put in but like I don't know there's
something impressive to me about
actually seeing performances like that
that's why Keanu does as much of the
action as can white why we over train
our cast to be you know part stunt
performer as well and we know we wanted
the same work and the same kind of
credibility out of the animals in this
uh I want to talk a little bit about the
editing process when you're putting
together let's arbitrarily say the
Morocco sequence with Halle and Keanu
fighting talk a little about how much is
that all figure it out on set in terms
of how you're going to be cutting it how
much is it working with your editor
because some of the editing I mean it's
it's all about the editing to put
something like that together again
I'm a big fan of live performances live
dance or old musicals or you know
exhibitions anything like that and
that's why I shoot the way I do it's not
really a [ __ ] you back to anyone going
like we don't use shaky cam we don't use
I'm nothing against shaky can't have
nothing against tighter shots or fast
editing it's just that's not what we
were tried to do in John wick so rather
than how most people do it will teach
the cast come in the camera and see it
on the day they try to capture as much
they can for the time they have and then
the editor figures it out way back in
prep with the rehearsals I'll have my
cameraman come to rehearsals three or
four months out so they're acclimated I
have my cinematographer come there so he
knows where to put the the wider you
shoot you limit your other departments
if you're not telling your
cinematographer that you're gonna shoot
wide into this long dolly shot he's
gotta know where to put his lights so
now he's scrambling to try and make that
work and then the cameraman you just
asked the stuntman to rehearse two
months but the camera have rehearsed for
an hour
my most films and that's why you get
that kinetic sense because they're just
they're missing they're trying to find
it and the Wardrobe guy he hasn't period
cuz he hasn't seen is he's only got one
suit so you can't script that suit and
that's how it all starts to go to [ __ ]
so we're like okay that's happened too
much we're gonna treat this like a live
show everybody's coming to the
rehearsals three months out so the
editors there he understands Evon shift
is my editor he's been my editor for the
last two films we like what we call
symmetrical editing 90% of the the
scenes in John wick weather astronaut
will start very wide medium tight tight
medium wide and they'll be symmetrical
we find that interesting because it
feels like you're bringing the audience
in it's almost like a slow push like you
guys are sitting right now and you're
watching the screen here in IMAX the
screens a little bigger so it's a little
bit more what we're trying to do if it
was a more of a regular screen you could
just take it all in without panning your
head with IMAX you can sit here and you
kind of got to search the screen a
little bit to follow the action that's
kind of what I'm trying to get when we
do the editing style that we're doing
it's not so much of a massive
perspective shift like going over the
shoulder over the shoulder and
flip-flopping the ankles it's slowly
bringing you into the scene slowly and
you come out it just makes you relax and
become more observant of what's going on
and that's kind of the editing style
that Evan and I have always tried to try
to get with the action so it's like
you're sitting in a live theater just
watching the performance you just add
there's a guy on the stage
there's the guy on stage and look
there's something oh there's something
going on down here and that's what we
talked about quite a bit so that's the
first thing the second thing is like a
lot of times especially because I shoot
on actual locations you know there's
lots of I have no idea like zero like we
lost three locations in Morocco we lost
in Marrakech we lost in Fez finally we
found the town that we shot in a swara
that we played for Casablanca and we got
our first location we're ready to go and
I don't know if you can tell by that but
it's a huge fishing village so when we
got there in the summer after having
scouted it well we didn't realize how
much fish it was being brought in every
day and there's over a thousand cats
when we got back there okay I don't know
if you know anything about dogs and cats
but like they're distracting to each
other so we literally had our thirty cat
Wranglers clean out the fish market and
it got so crazy we had applications to
the next square over and that changed
the configuration so while we know
patterns and sequences it took the stunt
team another day like we didn't sleep
for a weekend just trying to reconfigure
it so we could share our camera angles
so it's in answer your question it's
it's a set and it's as as organized and
planned out as we can make it always
having that 10% planning to be as
organic and as liquid as possible to
make make room for changes again we
don't try to teach the cast 10 moves and
hope they remember it we have a little
model the best way to fake being good is
just to be good so we try to just train
them as stunt performers and we don't
worry about just having memorized ten
moves so we want them to be able to
change and adapt on the day so you'll
hear hi halli still gives me quite a bit
of [ __ ] she's like we trained for five
months and then we make it up on the day
and that's not far from the truth like
she was taught all the pieces and has
this toolbox of sequences and moves and
then I might go okay take section one
put it over four four over here five
here three is not working
I very much like a dance choreographer
will change routines but the background
oh no they're pieces and we just move
and mix to make it feel more again it
can sometimes I do it just to liven
things up I'm curious how long was your
first cut compared to the finished film
ooh
the directors bane
four people don't live they don't
realize the first cut is where you put
everything in there and then just to see
what you have and the first cut can
sometimes be very long what's the great
quote if you don't have enough to throw
away you don't have enough so I think
our first one came in it and that was
pretty proud to get it down to two hours
and 44 minutes to 44 was I think my - 44
- 45 was my directors assembly and then
the director's cut which was so much it
was like 2 hours and 29 and a half
minutes and I was really proud of that
and is that something that like you were
the 229 cut was that something that like
you were like oh you could watch this or
was it like oh no we still have a way to
go but I you know I could watch like a
Jackie Chan video all day long you know
I mean I could I mean I still love
Lawrence of Arabia I still love the old
seventies films were like you know
running time was not an issue like that
was your Sunday like I'd go with my mom
and dad to the to the movie theater and
it's like alright bring it and then
you'd watch Lawrence of Arabia like
twice and there's six hours gone so like
I have a different kind of endurance for
that but like it was definitely
watchable it just you know for you guys
if for every I'll so like you're pacing
the two biggest things the directors
really got to worry about is always tone
like what Toni writing is this funny to
calm you don't confuse emotionally the
audience too much unless that's your
goal and then pacing you know like you
want to give action like you know you
guys know like you watch any action
movie there's a lot like John wick is a
great example
first one there wasn't a single piece of
action for 22 minutes like can't even
talk for 22 minutes like we knew that
going in we're gonna mess with pacing
and then it goes and yeah oh this is
weird
and then it goes like we wanted to have
that jump start number two's different
we started hot and got really slow just
to lay by goes Jesus this is born then
boom okay but wake you back up number
three I was trying to be again I'm
somewhat of a new director so I like
messing with things and still trying you
know we wanted to keep it going you can
feel the first 20 minutes they're like
non-stop there's a ticking clock and
then it's like put on the brakes
let's talk and give you some story and
show you some of the world and then
there's when he gets back in New York
it's okay fasten your seat belts here it
goes and that's the fun part I mean I
don't think you can have a really
interesting
ding fast-paced action movie without
having what I would not consider slow
but definitely you know put the brakes
on for a little bit and enjoy the film I
love the experience of sitting in a
movie theater and watching I love a live
show
like I mean Hamilton had slow parts
tensed up me or anybody else was seeing
it I thought it was great
every good dance performance has those
really dynamic flashy moves and then it
has this intimacy that you know suction
to the performance that's all we try to
get here
I'm assuming that there was what was the
last sequence you cut out of the movie
that you know like the last thing that
almost made it into the finished cut and
why did you take it out
mmm good question the last thing we cut
out there's a scene randall duck him the
doctor the case John wick helps out and
thanks oh well he had a scene with the
adjudicator and it was an interesting
scene because he was punished for his
his helping John wig and why it's fun
it's good it just we had to keep
intercutting back and forth between John
and the desert back to New York and we
just felt it was one transition too many
and it kind of stopped what was already
a slow slow act so we kind of took that
out to help move things forward to get
to New York a little quicker was that
sequence like over a minute or was it
something she 90 seconds it wasn't it
wasn't a lot but like you know when
you're watching something and there's a
rhythm going 90 seconds can feel like 10
minutes you must have test screen the
movie I'm curious what did you learn
from those test screenings that impacted
the finished film people's tolerance of
headshots now honestly you know you test
screen against wide demographics we did
a blind testing for people that don't
know that's they purposely screen out
people that like action movies or have
seen John with one or two so that
audience one doesn't like action movies
and had never seen John wick 1 or 2 so
interesting interesting notes some
interesting reactions of ooh wow why
which is good but you also learn things
about you know even though they weren't
action fans and it was a few hundred
people it was like you know seeing Halle
Berry in the role the world-building the
color at least you know I got a couple
well at least it was competently made so
that's good I feel good like my editing
and my my lighting was successful and
the camera wasn't too wacky
so that was good my choice of wardrobe
was okay they may not understand like
we're what we call hyper real and John
wig you know it's a little over the top
so they kind of got the theatrics and
what we're trying to do in terms of
creating a you know basically a
live-action anime or live-action video
game so they got that and you also get a
real sense of what they can endure and I
mean that in terms of what we were just
talking about pacing what they're
willing to sit through when it's not one
of your interests or passions and that
really helps cuz like I got a lot out of
it actually actually I was really
against the studio for making me do it I
was kind of angry about it but at the
end I've never seen you angry I'm I'm a
pretty angry guy but I put into my work
now it you learned a lot as far as i
concerned about pacing and and tempo of
how we were doing things so while I
didn't take many notes about cutting out
it was a little like 40 minutes of
action they wanted me to cut I was gonna
do that the body count is over 100 it's
gonna stay over 100 but it was good and
there are some logic questions that was
nice to test that they actually
understood having not seen the first two
films so it was educational for sure so
did you make because you did a few test
screenings and did anything else
through all the test screening process
impact the finished film or yeah no we
up until I think you guys yeah really
you guys just saw that was the first
time we had the ending we had we had a
very different ending up until literally
a month and a half ago that shot the the
final one the final scene with the
characters involved was new that I'm
trying to put my music but mine was a
much more abrupt ending if you can put
your heads around that one
it just didn't it didn't resonate well I
didn't have the impact I was hoping for
so yeah you talk about it and you try to
come up with a better way of ending the
film that was a big thing and trying to
think what else we had those that was
the main thing was just really about the
ending like we we knew we had something
fairly decent it's just okay you want to
leave the movie with everyone going okay
I'm satisfied but what's next you know
and there you know there's a million
things I could say about the ending and
why we end all these chapters like we do
and mostly because it's a chapter sure
you and Keanu obviously have a great
relationship while making the third
movie what was the biggest fight you had
and why if you had one no we don't
really fight we've known each other for
a long time we've been kicking the [ __ ]
out of each other for 20 years was there
a strong disagreement or something um
I'm just gonna interject and say there's
a glass house in this movie yeah and I
watched I was very lucky and I got to do
a set visit and I watched Keano do
stunts
after stunt after stunt after stunt like
it's unbelievable what he's willing to
do and I'm just curious at one point
does he ever like just say okay enough I
got you know you know what I mean
not in three films I haven't seen and no
I did three matrixes with him I helped
him out when he directed mana Taichi and
I did Constantine with him and now three
John wicks and I've never seen him knock
it back up it's crazy
he's a pretty I mean he's a very
impressive man he's my favorite human to
work with on the planet I mean I can't
say enough good things about him he's
incredible you know will disagree with
motivations sometimes like I don't think
it was an argument but how to do the
scene in the tent with the elder and
what that was supposed to mean and all
and stuff that was a point of big
discussion and the ending was a prior
two biggest discussions but they were
all very constructive and positive I
mean he's the most non confrontation you
see him in Charlie but I swear he's
incredibly non confrontational he's the
most collaborative cast member I've ever
worked with I mean
you know I sit here as you know the
title says director but you know Co
collaborator and co-creator is
definitely Keanu Reeves which action set
piece in the film gave you nightmares
horses men horses they're tricky now the
horse thing was good and at the end of
the day and I got to put my lead actor
on a horse going 35 miles an hour down
you know the elevated train of Brooklyn
and like you know we rehearse and we do
things we put safety lines on we do a
million different things but you know
[ __ ] happens sometimes you try you know
it's always nerve-racking and Keano has
like you know how the respect of
everything we do but like you know he
just doesn't know how to say no so
sometimes you have to watch that and the
horse is just wooden I mean we were
supposed to be getting to make that
sequence work the way we wanted and we
only got half the sequence that was
planned we needed to be getting 10 to 15
setups a day the setup is part of the
section of the sequence and on day one I
mean we only have the elevated train in
Brooklyn it's summer which was even
dumber for me to shoot during the summer
so I have like eight hours of darkness
and I think we got one set up by 4:00
a.m. so like day two I was already a day
behind so that was pretty bad and that's
because the horses just wouldn't they
didn't want to come out of their trailer
that day it was just you know animals
have a bad day when they're done they're
done and they just weren't responding so
we had a like column down take him back
to the stables you know bring out the
second set of horses from LA and then
try it again and that's when it started
working I believe Darren Prescott was
your second union director good Francis
I believe if I remember correctly when
you were filming the movie or getting
ready to film the movie there were a few
set pieces that you guys that he was
still trying to figure out how are we
gonna film this thing was it the horse
stuff was it the motorcycle stuff what
were the sequences that you guys were
because you've been doing this a very
long time so for and Darren's been doing
it a long time so for you guys to be
struggling means like it's holy-shit
hard yeah I mean when you write
character rides horse does this to
motorcycles crash yeah your head goes
okay we'll use the stunt doubles here
we'll see Jesus face we do a face
replacement here and then you know the
the more then
you know arrogant and difficult director
says no we're not going to use a double
we're not gonna use that we're gonna
have Keanu Reeves do it that throws a
wrench into things so when I told
they're like no we're gonna do this
let's figure out a way to do it so the
first round was a horse thing how do you
get Keanu on and do it safely and not
kill your lead cast member because they
don't want to do that yeah that was a
little tricky and him and our stunt
coordinator Scott Rogers figured out a
traveling safety rig that went above
Keano and all the horses and they still
crash the motorcycles live and did all
that stuff so that was pretty impressive
that they figured out relatively quickly
like within the first two months and
then when the motorcycle sequence again
you have a lead actor that can ride a
motorcycle more than or better than most
stuntmen and then you close down the
longest suspension bridge in the United
States the Verrazano and then you got to
give all the stunt guys swords and then
you got to try not to stab each other as
you're going 65 miles an hour
little tricky little tricky we were
trying to we saw this movie a couple
years ago called the villainous and then
you guys seen the villainous very great
great film sorry tangent yep his brother
was the one that got the thing in the
head anyways when we had to do that
sequence villainous is a great movie so
we thought okay that's great and we got
to talk to the drought to talk the
director some of the people that made it
and we're really impressed by how they
did the digital stitch in between
live-action and and and CGI and we
thought this is great John wick as you
can tell isn't ode to a lot of the
favorite action films it did from
Kurosawa to Leone to Bertolucci to
Tarkovsky - you know Jackie Chan all the
way through some of the Bruce Lee films
from the second film so we thought it'd
be a good idea to like you know we love
two great Asian films that we or from
Asian cinema the raid would give them as
we love that so you can see chap chap in
yen in there and the villainous so we're
like okay we're gonna do this and then
we started sitting down with Washington
it's like oh that's awesome you know
what that's great but we had no idea I
did it and we tried to break it down
like this really good they did a great
job so it took a little while to figure
it out and then how to do
it a little bit more live-action then
then even they had tried and to put our
lead actor in it they did something very
cool and sneaky by putting helmets on
everybody didn't know who's who
we took the helmet off and said you're
gonna see this guy and that took a lot
more planning than we thought it was
going to take and about two months of
rehearsals between the the sound stage
work and the live-action stuff you
co-directed the first John wick and
you've done the last the John with two
and three what do you think you've
learned as a director from the first
film to now the third film you you know
what I mean look before we did that Dave
and I both had a good solid 10 years of
second-unit in action directing behind
us and you know you're directing big
action a directing cast you know
everybody from Will Smith to Brad Pitt's
just watch the negative Stallone we had
done so much work on the Expendables and
some of the superhero things and Marvel
movies you know we were really arrogant
or let's say confident I guess yeah we
got this we got this no problem we're
gonna start going in but the ability to
talk to cast and really hold true to
that thread of what the character is
doing when you're shooting out of order
is you know it's it's an amazing skill
set that you have to have you have to
track things that you never really had
to worry about and it's just an action
guy the idea of blocking and saying
something with the camera other than
just catching a big explosion or
following a car chase is always
challenging like what are you saying you
just are you moving the camera just to
move the camera you're trying to say
something I try to capture an emotion
are you trying to bring something out in
the story
we're big silent movie fans which are
amazing they brought up a lot of stuff
without editing or without a lot of
talking or exposition so we just tried
to keep that the the motif on the first
week of we're gonna show you not tell
you and that was a big thing and then we
realized about I don't know maybe three
days in yeah we're not as good as we
thought we've cast so luckily we had
Keanu on our side that says a you're
gonna be working with whelmed a phony so
he might want to get you [ __ ] together
I don't like yeah that's that's a really
good idea man so let's get dummies guide
to how to direct
no we got in and just you start learning
that you just don't say go again you
don't just say that was great hit your
mark like how do you really talk to him
to bring out what's on the page and
really explain what's going on do your
homework and we had a pretty good idea
about that but like we really had to
hone our skills so we kind of cracked
down and really started working with the
cast a lot more than we did it's the
same thing you know like great as you're
putting a camera so we're great at
action but like can you tell a story can
you tell the story the way you want to
tell it so it's not just forced through
editing and that was a big thing and
then in post which is a whole other
world that most actually I just don't
have to deal with it's the things that
we're just talking about is like how do
you maintain the tone of your film
because the original John wick was much
darker and much more grounded and we
wanted a funner film so how do you
maintain you know basically killing a
puppy and have fun I think that's a
trick and then you know and then with
pacing and how to keep things grounded
how to give a little motion to something
and how to make it you know kind of
paste through and move through the
action you know again this is just my
third film so I'm a bit of a new
director still constantly learning
trying to expand you know you know
accept that you know I mean there isn't
a dad and go to set and literally
thought I was gonna [ __ ] my pants I mean
what's the better way I was scared every
day like you don't know you don't fail
you don't want to make mistakes you
don't want to be caught up not knowing
how to do something because you didn't
do your homework er because you didn't
read enough because you didn't research
enough because you didn't think about it
enough
so yeah it's terrifying but you just
can't be afraid of being afraid and you
just got to try and you got to keep
experimenting and when something goes
south you get her correct it and try
again
the next day you know it's like learning
anything else I guess which I would
imagine you guys have designed a whole
bunch of set pieces between the three
films is there a set piece that came
this close to actually being in a movie
that got cut out for whatever reason oh
I've been trying to build a glass house
for three movies it just costs a lot of
money
I love optical illusions anybody that
watches magicians live or some of the
bigger guys they know you can use glass
to refract reflect and that's always
fascinated me about you can see on all
the John weeks we do gags with
reflection and I think that's the
duality of that reflections all that
stuff is fascinating to me is the
thematic
and in human nature so we try to put a
little dot and everything that's why you
see the glass house and our the the
mirror room and number two in the glass
house and number three but I love that
idea of being able to see and not hide
anything and you don't see wires you
don't see the camera you don't see
anything it it just feels expansive to
me and it feels retro at the same time
is you know slightly futuristic you know
it's a cool vibe when what was it like
telling the studio or your producer
about the glass house and or the you
know the glass in this movie and were
they like uh no no there's a lot of
Tears
ya know they they kind of look at you
like that's great so how much are you
actually gonna build there like they
give you the nod like yeah that's that's
really cool cool yeah how big does it
have to be and then you start doing the
numbers and they go okay so do you
really need all four floors well maybe I
could do three and you always again you
always ask for more because you know
you're gonna get squeezed so I got two
floors and I started with all right and
it was much bigger when I started but ya
know they're good he's you just you
gotta fight for you want that comes at a
cost
you know the original schedule for this
film was I think it was I just had under
I think I had 67 days and then you start
baseball card trading he said yeah I
ended up shooting the whole movie
including Morocco and the additional
photography and 56 so where are those
days go well you trade the money of
those days to get bigger sets or cast
member or more camera like you know you
constantly got to deal with the the
budgetary restraints because it there
are financial limitations to what you're
making so fortunately enough I had two
great producers a unit production
manager and a line producer that were
very good at helping me manage what I
had that's how we got the glasshouse one
of the listen I think the one of the
things that the award season always
overlooks is stunt work and I'm just
curious what do you think it will take
to get stunts treated seriously for what
they are because they're incredible
people they make movies no III would
caveat my answer by like I love some
people I was one I came over one I think
I have one of the best on teams in the
in the industry for fight query are
and for what our guys do um I think the
industry does look it's not like the
industry or the Academy for that matter
is against some people getting an award
there's just a small difficult with it
difficulty with it meaning ok who do you
give the award to I mean the first
answer is always do you give it to the
performer that did the stunts do you
give to the choreographer that
choreograph the son do you give it to
the stunt coordinator that budgeted and
schedule the stunt do you give it to the
director that came up with the idea do
you give it to the editor that cut it
I've seen great stunt work go to [ __ ]
with that editing I've seen a great
performance amazing in person the guy
cameramen didn't get writer they shot
too tight or too loose you know I've
seen you know I've been in the room with
some great directors that I you know I
came up with which house keys I can tell
you as a fact they design their own
action so who'd you give the award to
you know something I'd never actually
thought with what you're saying right
now you've given me a different I'm up
I'm all for it 100% for it I think the
Department in itself should be
recognized to the Academy absolutely I
just don't know what would be the
fairest way to do it what have you seen
in the last number of years or in your
career so what stunts have you seen that
you're like holy F
yeah there's been some good ones I like
sequences so I don't look at a
particular stunt I look at a sequence
like what's a great card chase what's
the great fight scene what's a great you
know I I love Casino Royale I love the
opening of that I thought the the free
running of the park or would that was
you know the way they shot it and cut it
was very exciting
we keep Daniel Craig in was great you
know one of my best friends Tim Rigby
did the base jump off the Corvette in
the first xxx I think that's probably
the best done the last 20 years
ok the beginning of this movie has Keanu
fighting a very tall gentleman Oh bond
Bo bond a little bit I mean the sequence
is incredible how talked a little bit
about putting again spoiler for you but
talk a little bit about putting this
thing together because you can't double
someone who's 7 foot whatever
I was uh I couldn't figure out what I
want I need a couple more set pieces and
configure it was so I'm a big fan of
walking around New York and I ended up
in the New York Public Library just
wandering around I was like yeah screw
it let's just shoot here and I like this
would be a great place and then the same
thing we try to subvert so we're in this
big open space and you could put as many
stunt guys you want in I ended up
wandering through the stacks and I was
like this is great let's do it in a
tight space like this but not let's
let's not do it with a regular-sized
stunt man let's supersize and we'll find
the tallest biggest guy that could
barely fit in the library and and
that'll be the way we'll open the film
that'll be funny it'll be great it'll be
their creme Abdullah Jabbar and Bruce
Lee version of Game of Death
this is gonna be great except we
couldn't find an eight-foot-tall stunt
guy and I lamented my issue to a
producer and I know absolutely zero
about the NBA I mean I'm not good with
balls like football based so I don't
know anybody but he came in it's like
okay great I got what you need is is ba
ba I was like what's a bow bone and he's
like you brought up the videos of bow
bone at the time he's playing for the
the Clippers and I was like this is
great this guy looks amazing he's great
size and you know but can he act can he
do anything and they she had done some
commercials over in Europe and I was
like he's got some charisma he's got
this great thing and apparently has the
biggest hands in the NBA so from a
choreographer standpoint I'm like
perfect the hand cream dude Jabbar we
got this so boban flew from LA to New
York we gave him a two-week stunt test
with the stunt team and he was great he
was great and then we had him read Dante
which was pretty funny and no he did
great he had no problem with it and the
stunt team game thumbs up we put it in
the library and we had the talk and I'm
like look I know you're professional
athlete but you're eight feet tall
there's gonna be no stunt doubles it's
gonna be a 14-hour day are you okay he's
like yep and he was pretty good he's a
sweetheart of a guy he actually had a
kicked the the stuntman that you saw in
there and he didn't want to touch him
because his shoe is a size 27 so it went
from crotch to nose so like you couldn't
just put a pad right here
and he's a little tentative and Keanu
stunt-double a guy named Jackson Speidel
who's a fantastic stuntman just like no
not just kicked me and boba is kind of
look at him like have you seen my foot
like no maybe you should just in one and
I'm so good and we had a like we could
do this all day but it's gonna be better
if you just kick him and that's the take
that's in the movie just once and we
thought he was gonna land there and he
kind of landed we even Jackson got up
and went Wow pretty good it's a great
opening to the film thanks I think I
think most people would enjoy
I'm curious there's been a lot of talk
at the studio and just about expanding
the John wick universe the continental
what is the status of other stuff
besides the feature films right now the
they're trying to do a TV show called
the Continental it's based on the John
wick universe with John wick the
character of passing in and out I'm
currently in development
they're trying to get it all right but
they are they are working on the scripts
and the episodes and stuff it's
currently with stars which is Lionsgate
and stars right now but from what
they've sent idea wise to to myself in
Keanu it sounds really really fun
they've got a really great take on it
and you know they're currently in
developing this is not about John wick
but you've talked many times about
Highlander and I'm just curious where
are you at in in the development of that
the magic word of development
I love Highlander I love the original I
love the whole thing about it you guys
like Highlander I figured we did Gunn so
let's try swords right no I love the
love the theme of immortality I love the
idea of love through time I like the
idea of burdens of immortality about you
know how the only people you can really
trust and bond were the ones that want
to chop your head off
I think that's fast it's something we've
been working on now for two years it's
something I want to continue to work on
I just think it's it's a very deep
universe there and I think what happened
and again I'm just assuming from the
original is once you say there can only
be one and then you get down to one and
then you tried
make sequels that becomes difficult so
we're trying to not to back-end
ourselves into that and create a proper
story that we can build off of I want to
make sure that people in the audience
have a chance to ask some questions I
have another thing I want to ask but if
does anyone have any questions that they
want to ask so we can probably get like
six people or so right over there so if
a few people want to go over there and
and in there we go we'll see what
happens and but real quick while they
were getting in line what TV show would
you love to guest direct Wow
there's three I've been really impressed
with like I wasn't originally a Game of
Thrones fan but I think there's a couple
in there that I was impressed by you
know if that was still going on I'd like
to take a stab at something like that
all the bastards I thought that was
incredibly well done I just I swear to
you I just watched two episodes of Cobra
Kai the second season this morning
[ __ ] genius I love Johnny I think
it's so simple and yet so twisted in how
they did it and then I've been watching
a lot of Barry I think just in the
simplicity and the funny and the
darkness of I take I think Barry be my
choice to answer your question the this
if you were not watching Barry Bill
hader's Barry and HBO
phenomenal and the episode that was just
on the other night was jaw-dropping yeah
big fan let's open it up to the audience
hi I'm curious about your expanded
roster of writers that you had on this
movie as opposed to the first two and
kind of how the story developed after
the brainstorm that you mentioned at the
beginning and kind of how you assembled
that team as the process continued good
question again in the first film when we
got the when Dave and I came on board
John wick was written by a guy named
Erik Kolstad he's the creator of the
John wick thing that you see his name up
there John wick was originally 65 years
old a retiree from Cold War with a ten
year old German Shepherd and he killed I
think three people in the first script
that changed
I think it was the idea like Derek
brought some really into the gold coins
were part of it but it was more of a
Cold War it was based more on practical
stuff like if you were a spy from the
Cold War you wouldn't have cash you'd
have gold bullion that you could trade
in any country nondenominational that
kind of thing he had hidden a gun behind
a brick fireplace he had all so there
was things and he did there was an old
hotel in it that was called the
Continental that had the concierge and
had the secret little speakeasy
underneath but it was much more grounded
and I'm a huge fan of Greek mythology
and all that and obviously you can see
the references the names using the
characters and that's what we wanted to
kind of hyper stylize and comic book and
an anime it out a little bit that was an
idea we all kind of gone on and Derek
jumped right on board that we started
doing all the the the Greek and Roman
God mythology study and kind of twisting
it like that and at the end there was
kind of a happy ending I guess you could
say in there in the original script then
after Keanu got involved we got involved
it all became much more twisted and odd
it's a world of bad guys my point being
is when you write a script most of your
action movies they're you know the guy's
an assassin but he's got a good heart
something happens to his wife and then
he redeems himself and we go with a
little bit more of the darker Fae
ballistic themes of not so much
redemption but fate and karma and grief
and obviously consequence you do bad
things bad things happen to you and
that's never gonna change and that's
kind of why we end the movies like we do
because there is no in our mind riding
off into the sunset
there's no it's not gonna get better you
know and he's not gonna get rewarded so
do you point different writers bring
different different things to it so
that's kind of how we got the different
writers
hey I loved it thanks thank you so much
uh I'm really curious because you have X
amount of years you've so much you've so
many years of like experience with
choreography and doing stunt work and
all that amazing stuff and I know you're
booked for like the next five plus years
or so with all your different projects
but like I hope I don't know yo say I
don't know that being said are there any
like musicals you have in mind that
you'd like to tackle at all whether they
be like reboots or things from Broadway
or we did the premiere in New York a
couple days ago and I sat right next to
the lin-manuel you guys know who that is
Hamilton is one of my all-time favorites
uh I didn't know I said I'm literally
sat next to him and he was cheering
louder than anybody else in this theater
so we ended up with a great conversation
afterwards and you guys know who Bob
Fosse is yes one of the Triple Crown
probably the only man out there that's
ever won the Emmy the Oscar and the Tony
in the same year I'm a huge fan of Bob
of fauci's and his career and what he's
done from all that jazz all the way onto
Pippin I I think that's amazing anybody
that comes to our place and and five
minutes talking to me knows that I love
dance choreography and that's where I
steal most of the ideas for martial art
choreography sooner or later somebody
else will catch on I'm sure right now I
think we're the only ones they've
trained that way the answer to your
question is yes I think to be able to
express yourself at one of those base
levels of human experience or nature
which is dance to have that and be able
to tell stories not just that our
musical or or meant just for the sake of
being a musical but actually tell a
story that way like up on a lies Dave I
think that would be a directorial
challenge that I'd like to take I know
it sounds funny coming from the action
guy and stuff but I would love to I
would absolutely love to if the if the
script was written by someone that was
trying to say something more than just
let's dance and sing yeah yeah it seems
like it'd be great fit Thanks
hi there I just wanted to know as far as
the romantic aspects between John and
his wife and we used to see a lot more
flashbacks in the first one
can you see more of that happening
towards John wick for do you think that
maybe you know his wife could still be
alive is that even a possibility or I
think she's bringing back I think she's
passed away or what about I live out the
back story between Bridget Monaghan - I
think she's a phenomenal actress but I
think she's passed out but I know you're
saying the romantic interest I think
again if this was like say our good guy
typical action movie yes we'd flashback
there'd be new scenes in every movie I
just don't feel like beatin the audience
over the head with that is really what
we're trying to say it's about grief and
it's the chance to experience grief I'm
sure we've all had a bad day or lost
someone or lost something that we care
about and we've all needed time to
recover from that I think you know the
universe takes and gives as it sees fit
but how we react to it is ours it's very
private thing so once you lose something
and if you were robbed of that time to
grieve to express yourself I think that
would be more frustrating than even the
act of losing and I think that's what's
important here and know what John's
trying to get and that's his main
motivation so rather than do a flashback
or something like that and bring back
his an image of his wife I kind of chose
to be a little bit more symbolic and go
with the ring so what John does in the
elders tent is more symbolic of giving
away the last thing he has or the last
part of John versus that which is the
ring and I think I mean you guys got it
right all right I don't think you have
to beat the audience too much John I was
in the bathroom for that part that's why
was that little segue blu-ray right
after the desert had a peak and print
hold it but what about Halle Berry's
back story do you think I mean it seems
like she has something going on with
John wick are we gonna see more of that
or she done you know those are all good
questions I I truly do not know I like
Sofia I think it's a great character
again an overall answer to a lot of the
questions you guys may have have is as a
director you come back and
it's funny and I learned from the
Wachowskis when they're doing the second
Matrix I was really happy to come back
and do it it was something I was very
proud to be part of and they look
miserable what's up and they were like
curse of the sequel curse of the sequel
like how do you be original the second
time over and give everybody what we
love what we loved about the first
matrix how do you get that feeling that
nostalgic feeling of wow I was really
impressed do it again and then make it
different because if you do the exact
same thing it doesn't have the same
impact and you're like well they just
copied themselves so not only do I try
to do different set pieces I try to
different storytelling devices
you know flashbacks a symbolism
symbolism flashback that kind of thing
and if you're gonna do you know any kind
of romantic lead or bring back
characters like I love common from the
second guy I love my cast in the second
film you know I love John Leguizamo I
love that it's just I don't want to be
stretching and trying to use some cheap
device like you know I you don't think
there is people talking about why don't
you just kill another dog like for me
you get one puppy a career so you don't
want to keep tugging on that but also
it's the same thing I don't want to keep
tugging on this thread of why for grief
like you have to create new motivations
as you go if you can continue a
franchise and that's I wouldn't say the
struggle but the challenge if we were to
continue this universe in any way or
number three is just how do I get the
same things across you guys and make it
fresh to make it new or give you
something to think about and that's
always the I guess that's what we think
about most when we're trying to write
the story we have to get the next person
I'm not trying to be difficult
just running I'm talking the parking-lot
to be great uh just wondering uh do you
think John wick could have killed Thanos
better than the Avengers oh is that a
question
and where's there ever a second name of
the chapter other than Parabellum it's
funny I I whatever I have a fetish with
Latin I like Latin phrase I like the
etymology of our language and how to say
things with words because I think that
that's a big thing whenever you're
writing I try to get out sometimes the
lack of saying something is stronger
than saying something sometimes the way
you say something of the how you say
something or the what you're trying to
say comes across in different ways and
languages our main tool for that
so to understand it I think is very
important for anybody that wants to get
into writing of any kind and it was
let's just say it was a bit of a
struggle when you're starting or
developing a project to reach an
agreement with the people that are
handling the financials of it and it a
certain point where I was very
frustrated I just kept writing
Parabellum Sivas back comparable and it
was my little way of saying yes I will
go to war for what I believe in and
we're like yeah sounds good but it's
also I wanted to differentiate you know
we call them chapters so it's not just
John wick John wick to to gentleman
three and I wanted to give you know the
Dennis Miller and me why don't you give
everybody a chance to to local learn
something so I think everybody should
learn a little Latin so para bellum now
if you who here doesn't know what para
bellum means it's for war that's you
know and if you went and learned the
whole phrase see this pack on para
bellum you learned a little something
and now you've associated the word with
John week three so it's a bit of
branding and marketing as well hi thank
you so much for this wonderful film I
was wondering if you could just talk a
little bit about your journey from
stuntman to second unit director to
directing some of the best action film
and kind of time brief over holiday
Thanks
you know I honestly it I'm sitting here
I was sitting there last week now I'm
sitting here I don't know it's like
anything in your life you know I don't
think it was really a career choice or
anything like that I grew up in Palmer
Massachusetts little town went to school
at USC I want to be a doctor fighter
and then uh I you know we started doing
martial arts when I was 10 I started
doing some judo and some karate and all
the stuff there wasn't much to do in
that little town came to USC and my
roommate was actually in the film school
when I was like you've got to be kidding
me you can major in film like Eiger up
doing construction and farming so okay
that was seemed like a pretty good major
literally got into the kickboxing and
doing some martial art exhibitions was
recognized by you know I did an
exhibition bout in Hollywood and some
stunt coordinators were the audience and
said hey you know would you be
interested in being in a really low
budget film doing some martial arts I
said well okay I'll try it you know it
sounded fun I was only 20 years old at
the time and I made a lot more money not
getting hit they did getting hit in the
head so I thought that was pretty cool
and literally I just I fell in with the
right people I love movies I've always
loved movies since I was you know a kid
with my dad on Sundays watching all the
James Bond's and Steve McQueen's and
Charlie Bronson's I mean I grew up
watching Clint Eastwood and the Sergio
Leone films loved Asian cinema I mean my
friend here Ron we were always a
sneaking down to Santa Monica at a
Laemmle theater before anybody knew this
guy named Jackie Chan watching that and
that kind of just you fall in love with
that and then I don't know it just it's
one of those random things I grew up
loving museums I love architecture I
love Renaissance art I love classical
music I love modern music and I don't
know you like to create I like to
sitting here talking with you guys and
when someone offers you a job where you
can do all of it and they'll pay you
I mean you jump at it and you sooner or
later you sit here after you put all
that time and going holy [ __ ] it
actually kind of works I I wish I could
say it was all by choice and design but
it was mostly through luck and passion I
guess and I had I more than anybody the
greatest gift I probably ever had is I
had great mentors I had a stunt
coordinator mentor that was one of the
greatest in the business are a rondelle
he was phenomenal
I came out with the Wachowskis I mean
that's film school for the extreme I
don't know anything about that whole
thing but that's amazing I mean they're
geniuses you know one of my friends is
Brandon Lee growing up got on great with
him and that
was a great experience as well Jan and
asana was my martial arts coach to this
day one most legendary martial artist of
all time and then you know where I'm at
now
my best friend Dave Leitch is just
directed Hobbs and sha Deadpool two
atomic blonde I just very fortunate to
have the people I have around me that
guide me through all this stuff thank
you sure hey how's it going good so you
know with that comment earlier just
about John wick and Thanos and all the
how John wick has kind of crossed over
into like the pop culture and and in
that sense it's like it's kind of a joke
or it's funny that he's crossed over
talking about like the Marvel Universe
but have you considered or maybe what
would even be the logistics of John wick
appearing in other franchises like maybe
fast and furious Expendables Kingsman
have you considered anything like that I
haven't personally I'm just concerned
about the John wick universe and making
something entertaining for you guys but
I'm sure there are forces out there that
consider stuff like that and do the
what's the key word not a psycho
analytics what that means marketing wise
and legalities I'm sure that's something
somewhere but I'm more concerned with
doing some original content cool I'm
also wondering about John wick versus
Godzilla exactly chance let me tell you
something you can't go wrong with adding
Godzilla to any movie or John wick next
question hi so you mentioned earlier
that every day you show up does that
scared almost to the point of crapping
your pants mm-hmm
I just know halfway there now for each
of the three movies when was your first
sort of moment of composure where you
could step back from the chaos and sort
of accept your success success evil word
still waiting I yeah I don't I think
when you're in it you don't really think
so much like that I mean you kind of get
caught up like I am massacre
so I read like every review of all my
films and also I'm even reading the ones
I'm should be checking right now
that's a little crazy I just like
knowing I don't know you're kind of in
it you just want to you get caught up in
the passion I mean if you like to paint
you're gonna paint where somebody says
it's socks are done suck you're gonna
paint it's just what you have to do I
like the business them in I like what I
do I'm like with the people I am I like
trying to tell a story
I like making pretty pictures I don't
know how to stop I don't know what I do
if I didn't if if the financial success
was much less than it currently is and I
couldn't make another movie that was as
big-budget as what this one was and
stuff I make a 5 million dollar movie as
best I could I'd make a million dollar
movies Miska I'd make a movie with my
iPhone the best I could I would find a
way it's just you know I love the act of
working with my stunt team I like
choreography I would you know still be
teaching martial arts or still be
working waste on team I'd still be
shooting something with some device that
I could you know so I think that's the
important thing and if you know you're
doing things that people love you'll
find an audience I don't think you go
look for the audience first I don't
think you go try to calculate how to do
it and if you do manage to get something
that people like and you do find a bit
of what you term success I guess I guess
you smile you thank the people that help
get you there and you try again that's
about all you can do thank you
so I love John wick so much in the whole
franchise that I got a tattoo on my arm
about two years ago great did you spell
my name it's right before he kills you
sup Tarasov in the first film is there a
specific reason why almost everyone has
tattoos I think if you if you look at
the tattoos especially in number three
here and you look at who wears them and
what they say there's enough hints in
there between the props that I've used
in the directors abode in the theater
and the the tattoos to kind of give you
a little back story of John again I'm
from the show don't tell school of
showing so if you really want to know
backstory it's there you just got to
look for it but I'm not gonna have the
scene
with the two CIA guys with the folder
going John wick he served in Nam and 30
like I think that's a cheesy way of
telling how badass somebody is if you
can't tell Keanu Reeves bad ass by now I
don't know so if you want to see
backstory and stuff like that I don't
think I need to have a scene of Keano
moping on about you know when I was this
beckon when I was 12 and so the tattoos
are theirs
those are all very planned they're made
from scratch Steve Kelly my makeup and
tattoo guy we put those together with
Russian Latin there's a little history
on John Wick's tattoo so if you look at
it it tells a pretty good story you
should be able to piece together where
he's from where he's going who he is why
he's done what he's done just by his
back tattoo and I think if you look
carefully into the other tattoos in
certain scenes you you know a little bit
of googling I think you figure things
out yeah I was just curious about like
the phone tellers and all of that - yeah
I just like the symbolism again I I like
visual things and what's a good visual
representation of times is I like the
tats sometimes I think they can be very
creatively fun I think you should show
Chad the tattoo just for the hell can
you see is that is John wick walking at
me or walking away from me you can come
closer
he's got the turtleneck yeah what we
call the tactile neck great that's
awesome thank you I'm flattered thank
you oh we could ask you a million other
questions but uh I think you have a full
day of press tomorrow and even more
press today oh do we have do these are a
few more people that do you mind going
over there with a microphone
[Laughter]
it was a it was a little bit more work
to make it you can make the few steps
over so I absolutely loved the movie it
was fantastic and my roommate just got
me into the whole John wick verse and
it's amazing
I'm currently I just finished on a TV
show that I worked on and I was there
for two years and I just declined a
renewal for my contract for the next
year so I'm kind of nervous and you're
saying you available I am I am but I
just wanted to ask you do you still get
nervous between jobs how do you tackle
that how do you go out yeah like I said
I really concerned about what to do now
I don't know I at least me there's a lot
of things I want to do so I'm always I
always kind of point together I never
really get nervous I'm not worried about
like you know I'm technically unemployed
in three days so like ya know I don't I
don't really get stressed up I mean
there's so much to do and so many things
to research and like you know again I
say I could watch musicals all day or I
could research Sergey Leone or I could
just go try to learn another language or
take a trip like there's always research
to be done to create an original story
you know if if you have passionate stuff
like that whatever your field is if
you're writing directing whatever I mean
you know there's no way to there's no
way it better to practice it than just
go do it so if you're writing write if
you're doing something you don't like go
find something he did too and you better
work at it you know
oh yeah no fear man you can't even if
you don't fear stop you awesome thank
you yeah it's so about like the Glass
House scene how many days of shooting
was that night thing I have two nine
nine days finished with the acting
scenes and the glass like could you read
put it back in or is that one take those
glass part I mean the breaking I wanted
well there's not enough glue to put them
back together well no like they bring in
another like they built we bring another
one yes we had enough for two again I
have a great stunt team the
so we had to do we had to do I think one
gag twice but everything else was pretty
much one takers we rehearse quite a bit
but when you see the long take with the
seven breaks that's all that's the real
deal that's a that's a group of stunt
guys they just know how to do it I'm
also gonna I'm gonna chime in and say I
was on set for one of the glasshouse
days and I watched Keanu get thrown into
one of those glass cases and hit the
ground I mean it must have been seven or
eight times
yeah can was different I'll go along
with you but it was like I couldn't
believe what I was watching in terms of
him constantly getting pushed against
that thing I was you know I was blown
away I am curious to what your question
was forget about standing up do you want
to say it I mean the stunt team or the
cast I got to repeat the question though
so people unlike and hear it yeah how do
you how do you choose the guns and and
make the modifications Jamie check
yep oh god no that is too much the babe
also talking about where we cope with
some of the the intricacies of the gun
food chamber checks and why I choose
certain weapons and how the different
manipulations work in terms of props and
techniques and the ya know it's pretty
funny I just wanted to say that with
what Keanu was able to do in real life
with guns and reloading he's
unbelievable like it's crazy again it's
funny John wick seems so hyper real and
fantastical and all this stuff like it's
a Fantasyland
that's the way the real guys really
shoot people you know like it's they
don't mess around you don't wing
somebody in the arm they don't shoot
with one hand I shoot competitively with
Taran Butler I'm actually enjoyed doing
three gun which is four people in less
pistol rifle shotgun I shoot with a
Glock a Benelli and in something called
a sig MPX for a rifle last name things
that can I use in the movie you guys
know in real life you do run out of
bullets right okay yeah okay well most
action movies don't address that fact
simple reasons one it slows things down
and two if you see or if you ever get
the chance for those of you shoot or
have trained it's difficult it's not
easy it's sometimes it's slow and
awkward and it takes training you can't
just go bang bang bang bang bang Bing
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing like you
actually gotta have hand-eye
coordination we decided we're gonna let
that go we're gonna show real time when
you see them adjusting straps on the MPX
or probably the hardest thing that if
anybody with any background in farms
does with the shotgun he's doing
something called quad loading he's
actually doing it and for anybody that's
actually tried that it's you actually
take four 12-gauge shells out and hold
them between your thumb and forefinger
so you hold it four rounds at a time you
see him slide twice go online Google
three gun championships or shotgun
competitions and you'll see quad loading
and it's incredibly difficult and cannot
trained months and months and months
just for the 5% of the audience that
actually knows what that is that's just
the kind of guy is he also shoot
right-handed and left-handed he'll do
reloads right hand left out he did strap
adjustment left hand right and he
anyone in the military or law
enforcement or competitive shooting
worlds would know and that's just part
of our thing if you know anything about
real jiu-jitsu a real judo you'll see
him doing things in here that the
regular people or the non martial art
people it looks like the same throw over
and over again to any of us that have
been in it it's like holy [ __ ] he's
doing that too holy wow that's
impressive and he's doing both hands
both sides just that's the guy is he
wants to go all in all out on it and the
weapons we choose are usually the ones
that we technically even the 2011 is
something we compete with with a
9-millimeter major which is you know a
new kind of ammunition fairly in the
last decade or so it's really come up
across and then the Bonelli's and the
shotguns and so everything we use is
stuff we actually practice with in our
real lives so that's kind of how we find
it I'm I wanted to do a follow up which
by the way it's again crazy what Keanu
does and being all real but there is a
sequence no spoilers of course where
Keanu was picking out some guns taking
one apart taking parts from one to the
other
where'd that idea come from and how
tricky is it to film something like that
you guys know who Eli Wallach is alright
so you know good too bad the ugly yep
and it's a scene we ripped off from good
the bad the ugly I try to rip off from
the best that's my gig a huge fan of
Sergio Leone and Eli walk we thought
that's fun well if Keanu is so good with
the automatic modern weapons why
wouldn't it be good with period P stuff
and that's a big guy he goes in he's got
one bullet the bullet doesn't fit so
rather than find another bullet build
his own gun I haven't got called on yet
and any reviews haven't gone but that's
for you gonna call me on it like the
canted pistol stance based off of center
axis relock or is it just more of a
stylish no that's where we found it
we trained with everything from LA SWAT
to some of the Navy SEAL Special Forces
JSOC to Russian Spetsnaz to all this
other stuff and then we kind of create
our own obviously there's no such thing
as gun whew you don't do Aikido and Aiki
jujitsu and judo and then shoot yourself
and the guy okay so that's a creative
Liberty we took but it's based on that
but then it's key a no doing his own
thing
but then when this is like the
character's motivation to use center
access versus you know isosceles or
Weaver uh close-quarter in motion it's
always about motion motion motion when
you don't know the environment it's very
easy to stand and shoot a target it's a
lot differently you're moving through
crowds and you don't know who's on your
side like in real life the bad guys
aren't wearing a big sound this is bad
guy so you got to be ready to move it
depends like kena's camera are both
left-handed but we will right hand it
and we're somewhat ambidextrous for
their reloads
so for Keanu we strain on both sides
when he goes like that he can easily
shift the gun to either hand on that
note I'm gonna force you get a little
geeky there I listen no no actually I
look I love that [ __ ] that's great but I
want the studio well you need to what we
call leave so I'm just gonna say that I
want it and I mean this sincerely a huge
thank you to Lionsgate for letting us
screen the movie early a huge thank you
to IMAX for being such an awesome
partner and for providing such an
incredible format for the movie going
experience again John wick three will be
in IMAX theaters this Friday for one
week and the format's incredible and I
can't recommend it enough
Chad congratulations on the movie in
your 95 present score on Rotten Tomatoes
thank you
wish you nothing but the best thank you
so much for doing the QA Thank You
Stephen thank you guys thank you thank
you everyone
you